this is all just kind of warm up for
title tuesday
warm up for the match in a few days i'll
play this but i might go
into open sicilian depending
i'll play 92 i'm not sure if i want to
go into open sicilian or close cecilian
um or i can start as a close sicilian
and then i could play d4 here but maybe
not
hey it's red dev welcome back yeah
thanks for the hype bits
so much hype and john knob
oh and ry guy yeah we have a stafford
gamut emote
i have a few more open emote slots
every time we reach like an all-time
high sub
number a new slot usually opens up
so if people have emote suggestions let
me know
there's an interesting idea here to play
knight c1 which looks really
just non-purposeful but the plan is to
play
play h3 uh because if this i play this
the plan is to play queen d2 knight d1
and c3
and the knight can't trade itself off it
has to move back
whoa it's johnob jonah thanks so much
gifting 5 subs really appreciate that
welcome i'm not sure if i recognize that
name
i guess you you sub for the first time
too wait it's my move
oh it's my move
oh okay i'm still in some sort of prep
but
um i've spent most of my time
okay so we're going to play c3 redevelop
the pieces
ignite will come here the plan is
probably
to play f4 knight f2 one of the issues
here is that
if i castle i lose a pawn so
yeah i want to play knight of two to
defend support the center
very tense position up on time somehow
and neutron makes neutron
with 100 bits do i just play d4 for the
holes
uh d4 is a bad move though
like that was a good move okay let's
take
and then let's not flag
okay we're gonna trade everything yeah
this is pure instinct now
yeah okay i think i'm fine
if takes i can't castle unfortunately
yeah this looks very fine oh that was a
bad pre-move
that was a really bad pre-move but it
might still be okay
uh let's play this
almost flag there no
okay what is this game
everything was just hanging and now it's
randomly equal material
wait i'm up a pawn somehow
okay i'm up two pawns
what just happened there let's go for a
mate
no let's not get mated
oh no oh no
she mated me i was up two pawns in the
end game
i couldn't stop it knight p6 was just
made in two
what was that game oh no
what was that that's so sad
she's probably so happy right now
look at this yeah she's so happy
oh man
that makes me so sad it's getting too
tense
is it a mate oh it's a mate